fue la última vez que escuchamos a
donald trump desde que abandonó la casa
blanca el exmandatario no ha salido de
su club privado de mar a lago y florida
trump rechaza a testificar en su propio
juicio y se refugia en la primera
enmienda de la constitución
estadounidense tiene que ver con la
libertad de expresión que aunque alguna
gente haya gente apretado sus palabras
de cierta forma él tenía derecho a decir
lo que él quería y él no tiene la
responsabilidad de que hayan tomado
estas palabras en serio para declarar
culpable al ex mandatario los demócratas
necesitan el apoyo de al menos 17
republicanos sabemos que eso es muy
improbable porque el 45 de los 50
senadores republicanos han votado
diciendo que no era legal
enjuiciar a trump ahora porque ya no
estaba en función es el segundo juicio
político contra la trama en menos de 14
meses
los republicanos vuelven a apoyarle pero
la brecha dentro del partido sigue
creciendo pero ahora con mucho y hasta
afuera pensaban seguramente tratar de
sanar el partido republicano de los
tronquistas pero hay un problema y eso
quiero trompistas son que más
entusiastas son y van a las primarias
los demócratas buscan poner a sus
oponentes entre la espada y la pared
saben que tram no puede ser destituido
como expresidente pero si inhabilitado
para futuros cargos políticos quiere
volver a ser presidente y postularse
para el 2024 y si él pierde ese oficio
entonces no se va a poder postular otra
vez para un puesto político a nivel
federal al tratarse de un ex mandatario
el miembro más antiguo del senado
preside el juicio un proceso que los
demócratas esperan que dure pocos días
para poder centrarse cuanto antes en la
ambiciosa agenda del presidente joe
váyanse
bien